un salon de barbier endroit des plus
symboliques pour un chef qui annonce ses
intentions de couper dans les dépenses
publiques
notre revue cibler les sortes programme
qui est créé aucune emplois pour les
canadiens
indochine souhaite dégager un milliard
et demi de dollars par année en
éliminant certaines subventions aux
grandes entreprises mais des
compressions supplémentaires seront
nécessaires pour revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire en cinq ans comme il l'a
promis le chef se veut rassurant il
promet de ne pas toucher aux transferts
provinciaux en santé et en éducation
justin trudeau lui met en garde contre
la proche conservatrice avec la proche
de stephen harper de andrew scheer des
conservateurs qui propose toujours
l'austérité et les coupes on ne peut pas
créer de la croissance économique en
coupant dans les services pour les gens
le chef libéral a une philosophie bien
différente
lui qui ne vise toujours pas de retour à
l'équilibré il maintient toutefois sa
cible de réduire le ratio de la dette
par rapport au pib et continue de miser
sur des investissements pour lutter
contre la pauvreté
comme cette promesse de bonifier de 10%
les prestations de la sécurité de la
vieillesse à partir de 75 ans nous
savons que les gens veulent avoir un
clan qui est versé dans nos communautés
a investi dans les personnes les
familles tout en restant responsable
les autres partis ont leur propre
recette pour regarnir les coffres
on parle de comment on peut mettre en
oeuvre
l'impôt sur les super riches on parle de
comment va arrêter les paradis fiscaux
le chef du bloc québécois veut mettre
fin aux subventions à l'industrie
pétrolière c'est forcément de l'argent
extrêmement mal placé et malgré nous de
l'argent québécois depuis une semaine
les principaux partis ont promis des
milliards en nouvelles mesures mais ils
n'ont toujours pas dévoilé leur cadre
financier complet ce qui veut dire que
les électeurs canadiens n'ont pas encore
toutes les données pour mesurer la
crédibilité des programmes qui leur sont
présentés ici louis blouin radio canada
toronto